see Ed Sheeran and the traffic is so bad
that we just got out of the car we're
not walking on the highway because it's
gonna be quicker yeah I walk walking on
the highway the best oh you don't want
to get out it's dangerous look we're not
gonna get hit by a car no clearly no
we're not
I'm so excited yet to be great just just
get out just get out abandon the car we
gave up so here that Sheeran and hooked
us up with some Tomatoes and the Red
Bull
this is so awesome
who ready for head ed where are you
go we don't want to not to see the pipe
will fly to my mother to another man
it's too far
hey guys so I forgot that I went to that
cheering concert I shout out this video
and then I forgot to post the video but
here I am posting the video I just
wanted to say hello and I wanted to ask
if any of you guys have actually seen
him in concert live because it was by
far one of the best shows I have seen in
a really long time I just don't go to
shows that often I used to go to so many
concerts all the time but man edge here
and freaking just really you just know
how to do it that's it for this video if
you guys aren't tuned fans let me know
let me know what else you guys have been
listening to lately I've just sort of
been listening to like Spotify radio and
just kind of going dude good next next
next find me something good to listen to
yeah all right I'll see you guys later
hope you guys all have a good weekend be
safe have fun oh yeah see ya bye that
hurt okay I can get to Afghanistan